comenzamos reporteros de france 24
gracias por estar con nosotros
el tráfico de animales salvajes es un
negocio cada vez más lucrativo algunos
estudios dicen que se ha hecho
equivalente a las drogas oa las armas
con valores que sobrepasan los 20 mil
millones de dólares y en las redes
sociales se puede ser testigo de esto
cada día miles de personas de todo el
mundo publican fotos o vídeos con
animales vistos como trofeos uno de los
objetivos aumentar su popularidad y
conseguir el mayor número posible de
visualizaciones y clics de me gusta
estos animales nuevos símbolos externos
de poder y riqueza
suelen ser casados furtivamente en el
cuerno de áfrica en la península de
somalia y vendidos a familias ricas de
la península árabiga nuestros reporteros
siguieron el camino de estos traficantes
desde somalia hasta los emiratos árabes
unidos- y antes de ver el reportaje está
con nosotros
miyuki duros millo que gracias por estar
con nosotros usted es una de las autoras
de este reportaje y cuál es la razón por
la que ustedes hicieron esta historia
el impacto masivo que este tráfico está
generando sobre la biodiversidad nos
interesó particularmente una especie el
leopardo porque en comparación con otros
individuos en extinción en libertad es
el más comercializado del mundo de
acuerdo con varias ongs por lo menos 300
cachorros de leopardos son capturados en
el cuerno de áfrica y enviados al golfo
al año lo que representa más de la mitad
de los nacimientos de este animal en un
año bueno gracias mío que volveremos con
ustedes después de ver el siguiente
reportaje
[Música]
venus es una pequeña huérfana de unos
tres meses
este que pardo acaba de ser liberado de
las garras de traficantes que estaban
listos para revenderlo en el extranjero
nos encontramos en somalia en el refugio
más grande para que partos de áfrica fue
abierto por una ong estadounidense
estos veterinarios se examinan las
heridas surgidas durante su transporte
a parte de un grupo de jóvenes guepardos
de diferentes edades y tenían las patas
atadas con cables
qué tienes pequeña
los nudos que retenían sus patas
provocaron una inflamación separada de
su madre sin duda asesinada por los
cazadores furtivos
esta hembra solo tiene un 30% de
posibilidades de sobrevivir en
cautiverio si la pata estuviese quebrada
creo que la inflamación sería mayor
déjame tomar una foto de las dos patas
los guepardos son animales muy delicados
y es por ello que cuando son vendidos
ilegalmente tienen una esperanza de vida
de un año o dos
la gente cree o son tan lindos que
quieren otro entonces asistimos a una
especie de drenaje de la vida salvaje
chus lo que es devastador para las
poblaciones de animales
la herida de venus podrá ser sanada sin
embargo ya acostumbrada a los contactos
con los humanos no podrá regresar a la
sabana nunca más incapaces de
reproducirse en una jaula los guepardos
están en vía de extinción
sólo quedarían unos siete mil en
libertad
el animal más rápido del mundo se volvió
uno de los símbolos de este tráfico que
genera más de 20 mil millones de euros
al año y que después la los espacios
naturales del planeta una de las rutas
de este comercio ilegal se origina en
los países del cuerno de áfrica los
animales son enviados hacia yemen para
luego ser vendidos a las monarquías del
golfo en medio oriente
dubai es reconocida como la capital de
la desmesura con su torre más alta del
mundo y sus hoteles de lujo siete
estrellas entre los símbolos de
prestigio más buscados las grandes
fortunas de los emiratos se vuelven
locas por los animales salvajes
[Música]
incluso a la familia real le gusta
ponerse en escena con sus felinos en
vídeos todo esto por unos cuantos clics
en las redes sociales
uno de los instaura merz más conocidos
se llama juan vidal buscáis a él le
gusta publicarse en internet con su
colección de animales y vehículos tal
como en este caso con su oso y su
lamborghini
si pones la mano así en el interior de
su mandíbula
de hecho y luego mira sus caninos así
y ahí está claro que existe un buen
vídeo
este multimillonario posee un zoológico
privado que lleva su nombre lo que en
los emiratos le da legalmente la
posibilidad de coleccionar todos los
animales que quiera incluso especies en
vía de extinción
cada día por 250 euros una decena de
personas viene aquí a divertirse a posar
con tigres de bengala o a alimentar
lémures de madagascar
a las puertas del desierto estos
animales exóticos acostumbrados a los
bosques tropicales son las estepas
heladas se vuelven prisioneros de este
zoológico minúsculo
grabamos a omaira al burka mientras su
parque animal era construido muy
orgulloso de su colección de animales en
jaulas
[Música]
las garras no están muy largas empezaron
a salir hace tan sólo un mes claro que
les gusta el bosque pero me aman más a
mí porque yo les doy más comida que la
selva a quedarme delgada
compra animales a lo largo del planeta
hace 15 años
en áfrica del sur rusia pasando por
tailandia y tengo todo lo que quiero
vehículos dinero animales cuento con
todas las autorizaciones para tener
estos animales un zoológico privado me
permite poseer estos animales porque
nuestras infraestructuras son buenas tal
como pueden ver no es mejor que un
zoológico tradicional en infraestructura
alimentación es lo mejor que hay para
animales
uma y del burka se dice contar con
papeles para cada animal afirmaciones
imposibles de verificar porque en dubai
nada es más simple que adquirir un
animal salvaje sin ningún control con
unos cuantos clics en páginas de
anuncios en medio de los animales de
compañía hay especies normalmente
protegidas contactados por whatsapp los
vendedores nos ofrecen muy rápidamente
cualquier tipo de felino este hombre
propone un guepardo de cuatro meses por
tres mil quinientos euros
esta mujer toda una camada de cachorros
de león vendidos por dos mil quinientos
euros la unidad son poco claros en
cuanto al origen pero dicen poder
entregarnos los en los emiratos en la
dirección de nuestra elección existen
incluso tutoriales sobre cómo tenerlos
en casa
[Música]
hola a todos esperan
y saber cortar las garras de un león es
muy importante para poder llevarlo a
cualquier lugar
en cuanto a los guepardos la placa
giratoria se encuentra en somalilandia
esta región de somalia ha reclamado su
independencia desde hace 30 años y posee
un gobierno autónomo el año pasado las
autoridades llevaron a cabo una serie de
arrestos sin precedentes entre los
traficantes de animales salvajes esta
mañana en el tribunal de la capital arg
esa se abre el primer proceso
en el banco de los acusados vendedores y
pequeñas manos acostumbradas a hacer
contrabando con los países vecinos
[Música]
tras años de laxismo las autoridades de
somalilandia han decidido tomar en serio
la protección de la biodiversidad
los traficantes corren el riesgo de ser
encarcelados el juez con poco incluso a
los miembros de una ong para que
presenten los guepardos en el tribunal
como prueba
la baba
nos tenemos
los traficantes reconocieron haberse los
comprado un cazador furtivo' etíope en
la frontera y esperaban revenderlos en
1500 dólares pero su cliente potencial
era un informante de la policía
cargos graves de los que estos
traficantes no parecen tener conciencia
sólida primero los arrestaron a todos y
los ubicaron en una celda luego me
arrestaron a mí
escondimos a los animales durante cuatro
días y les dábamos leche
tengo la costumbre de hacer idas y
regresos en vehículo hasta la frontera
como teníamos una solicitud de iu de
partos encontramos un proveedor del otro
lado para venderlos
fui a buscarlos con mis dos primos para
que me ayudaran con los animales en la
sala el representante del ministerio del
medio ambiente que permitió esta serie
de arrestos asiste a los debates
abdi nasir shaikh guarda fotos de cada
uno de los operativos este es el
vehículo de los traficantes son
procedimientos largos toma tiempo extra
aquí no habían recibido fotos entonces
contactamos a la policía y los detuvimos
los habitantes nos dijeron que los
traficantes ofrecían precios entre 350 y
500 dólares por cada pequeño
es mucho dinero un gran mercado el jefe
del grupo es condenado a cuatro años de
prisión sus cómplices a un año tras las
rejas
sí
por todo el momento
desafortunadamente los animales también
están condenados a permanecer en
cautiverio privados de su instinto
salvaje deben permanecer guardados día y
noche en la periferia de hergé sa la
militante por la protección de los
guepardos lo he market supervisa las
obras para ampliar el vallado las
autoridades le confiaron más de 60
animales confiscados en tan sólo dos
años animales que requieren de mucho
cuidado para llegar a la adulta que
tienen calcio
aguanto
estos animales cuando llegan tienen los
huesos muy frágiles muchos de ellos
tienen deformaciones en las patas
tenemos animales que llegan con
fracturas es por ello que debemos darles
suplementos de calcio
financiada con donaciones privadas
esta ong gasta siete mil euros mensuales
tan solo para alimentarlos
los mayores como en un kilo y medio de
carne de cabra o camello al día
maltratados por los traficantes más de
la mitad de estos guepardos habrían
muerto antes de llegar a su destino
todos tienen secuelas de su cautiverio
le falta la mitad de su cola cuando la
recuperamos era una herida reciente se
la cortamos
y está ansioso y se asusta con el ruido
reacciona mucho y lo ve con cada ruido y
963 en crime traumas por lo que vivió es
este ingreso
para que estos animales no permanezcan
el resto de su vida encerrados
la ong está en conversaciones con las
autoridades de somalilandia para la
creación del primer parque natural del
país el guepardo necesita grandes
espacios para ser feliz
dentro de lo posible lejos de rebaños de
cabras o camellos de los que viven los
locales
[Música]
a 30 kilómetros de la capital comienza
la inmensa sabana
aquí se necesita escolta armada para
cualquier desplazamiento
[Música]
lowry marker y sus equipos visitan el
sitio propuesto por el ministerio del
medio ambiente
una antigua edificación que existe desde
la época de la colonización británica
este césped aquí creen que podríamos
instalarnos porque ya hay una estructura
primeras señales positivas gacelas
jabalíes y babuinos huyen a nuestra
llegada señal de que las presas de los
predadores no han desaparecido
totalmente
lo he marker ya ha conducido programas
de reintroducción de guepardos al estado
salvaje en namibia una experiencia que
le gustaría reproducir aquí
las fresas también están en peligro de
extinción en este país y entonces hay
que preparar la cadena alimenticia a
botear así como el hábitat y
desarrollarlos antes de tratar de poner
una especie en libertad si está caendo
tovar o
la reserva debería abrir de aquí a un
año paralelamente la ong inició clases
de sensibilización en las escuelas pero
mientras el dinero de las monarquías
petroleras siga vaciando los bosques del
mundo entero
estos chicos de somalilandia tienen poca
probabilidad de ver algún día estos
guepardos en estado salvaje
[Música]
regresamos conmigo quirós autora del
reportaje que ustedes acaban de ver y se
habla de que este es un negocio muy
lucrativo pero a diferencia del tráfico
de drogas o de armas parece muy poco
controlado cómo se explica esto
creo que una de las principales razones
es que este tráfico no es considerado
por las autoridades como perjudicial
para la sociedad en comparación con el
tráfico de drogas o de armas
otra razón sería su diversidad hay
personas que transportan animales para
convertirlos en mascotas y también en
cazadores que matan los animales para
comerlos o para comercializar sus partes
en polvos o aceites y venderlas como
afrodisíaco
por ejemplo los cuernos de rinoceronte
son a la cóndor y los ojos
vimos en el reportaje a un medal mu cage
un emiratí que cuenta con casi un millón
de seguidores en instagram y que exhibe
orgullosamente en cámara su colección de
animales salvajes e incluso afirma que
están mejor enjaulados en su parque de
animales
todo esto es legal y los emiratos existe
alguna sensación de impunidad
es un área gris desde hace años en el
golfo es muy fácil para cualquiera tener
animales salvajes en casa aunque hubo
varios accidentes en kuwait un león
atacó una mucama filipinas qatar y se
dejó en qatar un tigre fue visto
moviéndose libremente como se ven en las
imágenes por una autopista entonces
después de varios incidentes las
autoridades especialmente los emiratos
árabes decidieron pasar una ley jurídica
de sommer y foc y ahora los propietarios
de zoológicos privados deberán registrar
los animales y con estas medidas vendrán
reglas y controles pero como vimos en el
reportaje estas reglas no están
estrictamente implementadas
esto usted en somalilandia cuando y
porque este país comenzó a luchar contra
este tráfico y tienen ellos los medios
para combatir a los traficantes
como se diría que desde hace dos o tres
años debes saber que en somalilandia es
una región que declaró su independencia
de somalia en los años 90 autónomos
actúa hoy en día es un estado autónomo
de facto con su propio gobierno y su
propia moneda pero no es reconocido por
la comunidad internacional esto limita
la ayuda extranjera en este contexto
para atacar los problemas de protección
de la biodiversidad usan métodos
diplomáticos una manera inteligente para
llamar la atención sobre el país de
manera positiva pues psiquismo
gracias miyuki duros por acompañarnos en
la realización de este reportaje a
ustedes también gracias por estar con
nosotros y recuerde que puede ingresar a
nuestra página web 324 punto com para
ver esta emisión y las anteriores hasta
la próxima semana